as if the grief of losing a child
weren't enough
imagine wondering if more could have
been done to save her
vincent salazar and his family are
mourning the loss of eleven-year-old
layla the baby of the family they called
her who loved tick-tock and denim
jackets
the families of all those who died now
waiting for answers on why it took the
police so long to confront the gunman
we're definitely going to want to know
but
right now it's hard to get answers you
know but
as time goes i'm sure we will um it's a
small town i mean
i don't know
too many police forces in a small town
like this that would know how to respond
to this
i'm hoping that my daughter's death
wasn't in vain and her classmates
deaths weren't in vain and that
something does change i mean anything
anything is better than nothing
timeline of events is critical and why
police delayed before entering that
classroom when children in the school
were still calling 9-1-1 and panic
parents outside pleaded with them to go
in
to the clamor for answers this admission
from a senior police chief was striking
hey from the benefit of hindsight where
i'm sitting now
that of course it was not the right
decision it was a wrong decision period
there's no no excuse for that
but again i wasn't there but i'm just
telling you from what we know
we believe there should have been an
entry at that as soon as you can hey
when there's an active shooter the rules
change
he was asked how this tragedy had
affected him
you know forget how i'm doing about the
parents
have to do something man for the second
time since the tragedy the governor of
texas was heckled at a news conference
for dismissing guns as the problem the
local democrat senator who did it
explained why
if these people out there in the public
push these guys they need to start
calling his office
and they need to start asking for change
we've also heard from the mother of
gunman salvador ramos
i have no words she says please don't
judge him to the innocent children who
died forgive me
the investigation into her son has
zeroed in on his online life concerns
others had about his guns and even
whether he was planning a school
shooting everyone i have one of his
words
that's his voice in a chat group on the
app ubo we spoke to one young woman who
he was in contact with who he sent
threatening messages to who said his
behavior caused alarm
he was given the nickname hugo's school
shooter and people be like oh hey look
at super school shooter
like
and he never tried to shut down that
nickname like he never
and he seemed almost proud of it you
know like it was
it was just like something that really
could have been prevented
yubo says it's investigating
whatever the warning signs they were
missed so too an opportunity for police
to act all of it leaving them wondering
here whether it could have made the
difference between life and death greg
milam sky news uvalde in texas